but last Jedi cameos to keep an eye and
ear out for Plus Justin Timberlake
schools Will Smith on Instagram
happy Friday my people Danny here I know
there is only one thing on people's
minds today and that's Star Wars the
last Jedi episode 8 is finally here I
actually saw it last night and I'm not
gonna spoil anything for you except to
say buckle the eff up last Jedi is also
filled with some a-list celebrity cameos
that if you blink you might miss them
but you're in luck because with the
scoop on the stars to look out for is
our resident Star Wars Queen ash
crossing oh my god coordination did you
have fun watching this movie last we
watch it together we watched it together
for us how many times to be close at
least 17 but yes there are some famous
faces who wanted to be a part of this
movie some are rumors and you know Star
Wars lore but here's who we know for
sure is in the movie Gareth Edwards who
directed rogue one put last gen AI
director Rian Johnson in front of the
camera for a special cameo and now Ryan
has returned the favor in Episode eight
you can look out for Gareth during the
movie's big climax on the mineral planet
crate also BD driver director Edgar
Wright is a blink and you'll miss him a
rebel meanwhile Joseph gordon-levitt is
actually in the credits makes a voice
cameo in the movie as one of the
gamblers on kanto bite as does Warwick
Davis who has been a part of every Star
Wars movies since Return of the Jedi so
creepy now mild spoiler here but in that
same gambling scene Finn and Rose are
instructed to find someone wearing a
floral pin well guess who's wearing it
Justin Theroux and I'm sitting there
like is that Justin Theroux
and I was like that is Justin Theroux
now I know has become sort of a
tradition to have big stars play
stormtroopers Daniel Craig played one in
force awakens so what famous
stormtroopers do we have this time
around ash not me unfortunately but it's
long been rumored that the Royal Bros
that's how they love to be addressed
Prince William and Prince Harry make a
cameo as stormtroopers on Snoke ship
they of course did visit the set and
were at the London premiere so I
wouldn't be surprised but you won't be
able to spot them if they are in it same
goes for Tom Hardy who also reportedly
donned the helmet and suit for a scene
and speaking of rumors apparently ellie
goulding isn't it to head-scratcher
on Wednesday she tweeted fans has
anybody seen Star Wars yet and seen
someone who resembles me in it awkward
if I got cut haha I don't know if she's
kidding or what but I didn't know I
definitely did not like at all but that
would have been a dick if she did sneak
up in there one thing is certain though
the movie is also such a beautiful
tribute to Carrie Fisher like I might
have all that okay I cried you cry oh
crap I did - yeah and carries beloved
dog Gary who we loved he also makes a
cameo as a creature there along with
Mark Hamill's son Nathan who is it in
this movie folks are you guys will have
to go - me neither
you guys ought to go find out for
yourself Star Wars the last Jedi is in
theaters now and of course I know the
Internet is divided on this latest film
and ash is breaking down both sides of
the force in a new video up on ETS
YouTube channel so go check it out be
kind to each other
exactly alright switching gears now to
another force of nature in the biz see
what I did there you see what I did that
thank you Will Smith has officially
joined Instagram will got an assist from
Ellen on how to rack up them likes
meanwhile Justin Timberlake Ennis Lee
welcome will with a photo of the two at
the 2013 VMAs writing welcome to
Instagram Will Smith this is called a
hashtag TVT which means throwback
Thursday which is a photo you post on
Thursday that you like that was taken in
the past well something tells me wills
response was probably more than what
Justin bargained for
JT thanks a lot man for the post and you
know the the brief education about
Instagram man because this is my first
day so I'm appreciating the the hookup
but man know what throwback Thursday is
I'm not like I ain't been a whole you
know oh and I heard you doing the the
Super Bowl so I want that to help you
out like just the things to avoid at the
Super Bowl is like just like avoid debt
avoid that I'm stupid
you too man I love you I am so glad Will
Smith is on Instagram I'm just gonna put
this out there but I dare JT to bring
Big Willie style to the Super Bowl
you guys imagine Justin and wheel doing
a little getting jiggy
dance break here's hoping fingers
crossed are speaking of dancing it is
time for new music Friday Eminem just
dropped his ninth studio album revival
and he's celebrating the release with a
pop up in his hometown of Detroit which
includes exclusive merch and mom's
spaghetti you guys get it he's weak arms
are heavy all right well the new record
features so many claps from Beyonce no
Leisha keys to Kalani and this one with
Ed Sheeran called River and I know she's
using me to try to play him I don't care
hi Sam but I should have said bison
saying after the first night but tonight
I am
Agito
holy water
little one
I'm curious to hear what you guys think
of Em's latest let me know in the
comments section meanwhile one of 27
teens biggest breakthrough artists
scissor is jump-starting your weekend
with the remix of her song weekend with
an assist from
I don't tell me about this
mmm-hmm funky right we'll get ready to
turn it all the way up with Major
Lazer's new track featuring J Balvin and
Shawn Pau
that is a wrap for today are you sure
you're subscribed to ETS YouTube channel
and turn your notifications on because
starting Monday we've got a week a week
of special end-of-the-year vids for you
and yours so until then thanks for
watching and have a great week guys